[music]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, please join me in
welcoming to the stage your MC for AI
Engineer Europe 2026,
Phil Hawksworth.
Good morning. Hello.
>> [applause]
>> Good morning.
Wow, what a lovely full Is it a full
room? Goodness me, it is a full room.
Welcome everyone. Welcome to sunny
London. Lots of smiley faces here this
morning. I think it helps that the sun
is shining, right? That helps us a
little bit. Come to London, we said, cuz
it would be guaranteed sunny weather.
We lucked out. Well, good morning and
welcome to AI Engineer Europe, our first
soirée into Europe with this event. My
name's Phil Hawksworth, and I'm very,
very happy to be your MC for just today.
You have Techatomorrow, uh but but today
uh you have me, and it's my my great
privilege. Um
it's a full day. I don't know if you've
looked at the schedule. I'm sure you
have. I'm sure you've been looking at
that with a great deal of eagerness. It
is a very, very jam-packed day, and it's
a jam-packed room. I was going to say
squeeze in to fill in the spaces, but
it's like a jelly mold in here. You guys
have uh have really filled the spaces
beautifully. So uh so so welcome. Um
so this is our first time here in
London. Um I'm curious before we get
rolling, uh where have people have
people come from? People from London
here today?
Ooh. Okay.
One one of you is delighted about being
from London. The rest of you are kind of
unsure, but okay. Uh elsewhere in the
UK, people from the north of England?
That's fine. I'm not I'm not trying to
out anyone. That's fine. One one person
came down from the north. Uh people from
the south of England?
>> [laughter]
>> It's It's interesting gauging the
different levels of enthusiasm. Uh
difficult to know also where the
north-south divide is. Uh people from
from just around England. People from
England here?
Okay, we're we're we're starting to
understand the levels of enthusiasm for
where we come from. People from
elsewhere in the UK?
Yeah! There we go.
Where's that enthusiastic person from?
Wales. Wales.
>> [laughter]
>> I had to ask. I had to ask. Of course,
the deep, rich, thunderous voice was
from Wales. Uh from wider elsewhere in
Europe, people come from further afield,
people from elsewhere in Europe? Yeah!
>> [cheering]
>> There we are. There we are. Okay. Just
people from the UK, that's how you do
it, by the way. That's how you do it. Um
I'm curious, who who thinks they've come
the furthest? Anyone want to open bid
for who's come the furthest?
Shout out where you come from if you
think you might have come the furthest.
Canada. Canada. Okay.
Good luck, everyone. Anyone Anyone want
to bid Which Which coast of Canada? We
talking east or west? Whereabouts?
Whereabouts? East? Ottawa. Okay, which
is on the
east coast. I know.
Uh anyone prepared to try and beat that
bid? Sri Lanka. Where's Sri Lanka? Okay,
I'm I'm going to start needing to get
Google Maps out to start look at the
exact Okay, so we've safe to say
welcome. Thank you for coming all that
way. Um safe to say I'm sorry, where?
Dominican Republic.
>> Dominican Republic. Yeah, you came here
for the sunshine. Well done.
Well done. I'm so glad it isn't gray and
miserable here. Never is in London.
Ever. Um well, thank you for coming all
of those all of that distance from all
of those places. Um we're very happy to
have you here. Welcome to all of you.
And you know, why do people travel so
far for events like this? Why do we
gather? Um
it's kind of an interesting time, I
think. Our industry is changing all the
time. I think it attracts people who
have a thirst for knowledge. I suspect
all of you here have got a real thirst
for knowledge. Our industry is changing
all the time. And I mean, I remember
when I first got started, I was putting
numbers on screens for traders to trade
off on the stock exchange and using very
antiquated, old technologies for that,
using kind of video switching. And then
web technologies came in, and we started
doing various sorts of like DOM
scripting with very sophisticated Java
applets behind the scenes.
And then, you know, there was Ajax, and
then there was web sockets. Technologies
were always changing, you know. I've
worked at software houses. I've worked
at agencies. I've worked at telecom
companies. And all the time the flavors
of web development and software
engineering I was using were changing.
And I have to admit, you know, it's I'm
a bit nervous standing here in front of
you and admitting this, but I was very,
very reticent about adopting the kind of
surging AI tooling and the the kind of
surging what we're seeing now. I was
really cautious about it. I'd kind of
like to think, you know, I I know best
when it comes to craft and touching the
codes and the engineering. I was very,
very cautious about actually putting my
trust in the emerging tools and the
emerging ways that we're we're building
with these new tools.
But I'm becoming more and more
optimistic and more and more kind of
cautiously optimistic, but very, very
excited about the possibilities now. And
it's because of the kind of work that's
been done by the people who are on this
stage and people in this room and how
we're talking and sharing this kind of
growing knowledge about how we can build
with these incredible tools. And so
my fear, I think, in the initial
thoughts of well, you know, my craft is
kind of going away,
that that fear is starting to subside
now, and I'm just seeing that the craft
isn't going away, it's just moving to a
different part in the abstraction. So
I think with that in mind, I'm really
excited that I can be here, and I can
absorb all this because this is really
the place to to soak up all of these new
developments in the world of AI,
understand how we can use them better,
how we can
further the craft of software
engineering, and as you'll see
throughout the day how that is
definitely changing. Um so this is
definitely the place to be for that. And
we're very fortunate that we have got
the support of some wonderful sponsors.
Uh Google DeepMind are today's
presenting sponsors, so our our our
thanks to them. Um also thanks to our
platinum sponsors, who are BrainTrust,
WorkOS, and OpenAI. And by crikey,
there's incredible support from such a
wide range of folks. You know, the gold
and silver sponsors uh here, we thank
them as well. So many of the people from
all these companies you've seen are here
at this event. They're out in the expo
hall. They're around. They're available
to talk to. Grab them. Make the most of
the opportunity and have some great
conversations with them. Um so before we
get on, I'd like a quick round of
applause for all of our wonderful
sponsors, please.
>> [applause]
>> So, we're going to get started in just a
second, but just a couple of quick
comments about the format of the day and
how the day's going to work. So, um
we're squeezed in here together in this
lovely room, uh which is where the
keynotes are going to happen. So we have
uh a number of keynote talks uh kicking
off in just a moment right here. And
then we'll have a short break, so you
can get to go and talk to some folks,
talk to each other, make new friends
uh out in the expo hall and around the
event. Uh and then we're going to split
into six different tracks. So we have a
number of tracks that have different
specialisms and and topics uh of areas
of focus, uh where you can choose one of
them right in here and others around the
venue. The details of that are in the
schedule, and we'll have a little recap
of that before we uh break a bit later
on. Um
so um
I think we're almost there, ready to
start. I think you're probably itching
to get started, and it's it's kind of
exciting because I think the the the
growth of this industry and the growth
of adoption and just the groundswell in
all of these these technologies and and
businesses being formed around this
these technologies, it's just exploding.
I mean, and that's that's been borne out
as well by the the growth in this
particular event. You know, from being
in the US originally and now branching
out into Europe and having such an
amazing full room of people and a just a
bustling community of people out here.
So uh
I know that uh the team at AI Engineer
wanted to say a quick hello and a six a
quick thank you and a bit of a welcome
before we get started. So I'm going to
hand over the reins very, very quickly
uh
to them for that, and then we'll get
into the talks for the day. So as we get
started, I hope you have a wonderful day
today. I'll be back. We'll talk more
during the course of the day. But to get
us rolling, uh it's the general manager
of AI Engineer. Please welcome to the
stage Lia McBride. Here she comes.
>> [applause]
>> Good morning, everyone, and welcome.
So you're going to be able to tell from
my accent very quickly, I'm actually
Scottish. So this conference for me is
very, very special.
I spent most of my career in London,
over 15 years, right at the heart of
European tech growth.
And so today is very special for us to
be bringing our first European
conference here.
Um this is our sixth conference now.
Obviously, our first in London, and
honestly, the energy around it has
completely exceeded all of our
expectations. So thank you.
AI Engineer has actually grown a rate of
900% over the last 3 years from our
first small event in 2023 in San
Francisco.
We did three events last year, hosting
almost 5,000 attendees. We're just
getting started, as you can see.
Um as well as our core events, we also
have a series of licensed events that we
do, our partner events across different
cities as well. This year, we're doing
Miami, Singapore, Melbourne, and Paris.
So if any of you happen to be in those
areas, check out those dates on the
website. Um but yes, London was our top
priority this year because really it is
some of the most important work in AI is
being done right here and in of course
in
in Europe. Just this morning we myself
and Swix were at 10 Downing Street with
Cal Beer Sohi, who is the first ever UK
Chief AI Engineer Officer who was
appointed in January.
And what was very clear from the
conversation in that room is the
ambition of the UK is accelerating very
fast. And that creates huge opportunity
for everyone in this room
to do very meaningful and career
defining work in the very near future.
So over the next few days, I encourage
you to do two things. First, learn.
Go deep, ask questions, challenge ideas.
And second, connect. Speak to each
other, speak to our sponsors, our
speakers,
and just make connections that will
create opportunities and progress.
Because this community only works when
we're open, collaborative, and
practical.
So enjoy this experience together paving
the way for the future of AI. Welcome to
AI Engineer Europe. Feel free to come
say hello any point. I'll be here for
the next couple of days. Enjoy everyone.
Thank you.
>> [applause]
[music]